hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the 600th video i've ever
uploaded to youtube and it's a quick one
it's a pretty simple one too um as i
spend more quality time with the nexus 5
and i'm going to be giving you guys my
full review quite soon so make sure
you're subscribed if you haven't already
if you want to see that i was playing
with a black nexus 5 before this and a
lot of people's personal nexus 5s are
now shipping and i ordered a 32 gig
white nexus 5 and that's what i'm
holding now but as i have them both now
in hand turns out there are a lot of
physical differences between the two so
it's more than just a gut decision in
terms of which color you want to get
when you look at black nexus 5 or white
nexus 5. so let's go ahead and check out
the differences it actually starts with
the box and you'll probably see a lot of
these differences when you watch
people's unboxing videos of the phone if
you haven't go back and watch them again
people who unbox the black nexus 5 will
show just one phone on the box while the
white nexus 5 actually has two phones on
it has a side angle view of the phone on
the box basically letting you know that
this is in fact the white one but
everything else about the contents of
the box are the same no fancy colored
headphones or anything now when you look
at the phones themselves head on there's
only one difference and it's not
immediately obvious unless you've seen
them compare it already but the inside
of the earpiece is white on the white
phone and black on the black phone the
whole front of the devices are otherwise
identical and that's the only way to
tell them apart i kind of like that
accent it kind of spices up the design
of an otherwise understated phone but i
think it would have been even cooler if
they had a multi-color led notification
light in there but that'll be detailed
more in the full review now another
thing when you look at these unboxings
is you're going to notice two kinds of
unboxings unboxings of the black nexus 5
will have protective plastic on the
front and the back and unboxings of the
white nexus 5 will have protective
plastic on the front the back and the
sides and the top on the bottom since lg
wrapped up all the glossy plastic on
this phone with plastic
and that's the thing the black nexus 5
is not glossy on the sides while the
white nexus 5 is it's a subtle
difference at first but you might not
even notice it at all while you're
holding it in the hand but there is
definitely a difference in material just
for the band around the black versus the
white phone having used both phones i
can say it makes a legitimate difference
in build quality worth knowing about and
if you're stuck choosing between black
versus white consider this difference
now both phones also have the same exact
ceramic button material so the buttons
are you know they're supposed to feel
tactile and they actually do so they
feel the same on both but with little
things like the sim card tray the
hardened rubberized feel of the matte
black nexus 5 feel more sturdy there's
also little differences in how they
fingerprint obviously the black nexus is
the same material on the sides and on
the back but it basically behaves
exactly the same way as the nexus 7 from
2013. the white model hides fingerprints
pretty well on the back but it shows
them way more on the sides because of
that gloss so it's an interesting
trade-off for an interesting design also
having the soft touch white nexus 5 in
my pocket is so far not dirtying up the
phone at all or causing it to stain
which is good because usually you know
this can be a legitimate concern for
soft touch back phones that are white
that's the same reason why the galaxy
note 3 is a different material for the
black one and the white one so basically
the takeaway here is that there is more
than just a color difference between the
black and the white nexus 5. there's a
more interesting design up for grabs in
exchange for a different finishing
material that may change the way you see
the device people reviewing the white
nexus 5 are going to talk about that
plastic band just a heads up worth
sharing so you guys can see there is
actually a couple of little minor other
things to consider when you're picking
one or the other color personally i'm
going to be sticking with the black and
white i think this in my opinion is a
little more interesting i like the
understated very simple design of the
all black nexus 5 but i also like the
stormtrooper look a little bit more uh
with the white on black nexus 5. so
that's going to be checking out like i
said this is just a quick video going
over the black versus white differences
but make sure you are subscribed to get
the full review video in your sub box
when that comes out very very soon so
either way thank you for watching and i
will talk to you guys in the very next
one
peace
you